-And finally, as I said,
this is our first show
in over five months,
and so happy.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So much has
happened in the news
that we never got
the chance to talk about,
so I thought it'd be good
to recap everything we've missed
with a little song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Let's catch up
on what we missed ♪
♪ First things first,
there's Taylor Swift ♪
♪ Wonder if she'll
write a song about meeting... ♪
-Travis Kelce's mom.
-♪ Politics and weird debates ♪
♪ All these random candidates ♪
♪ Listening to them all summer,
we're like... ♪
-Honestly, every time I hear
you, I feel a little bit dumber.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Twitter, well,
it's now called X ♪
♪ And HBO is now called Max ♪
♪ Everyone is so confused ♪
♪ They all look
just like this dude ♪
♪ Grimace Shakes
and Munchkin Drinks ♪
♪ All these new foods
make you think ♪
♪ Try them all, it'd be insane,
and give you... ♪
-Diarrhea on the Delta plane.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Burning Man,
it kind of sucked ♪
♪ Thanks to mud,
they all got stuck ♪
♪ That party was such a pain,
while the White House has... ♪
-A bag of cocaine.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ "Barbie" movie,
an all-timer ♪
♪ Double feature,
"Oppenheimer" ♪
♪ Other films were really
trying, but also asking... ♪
-Do you guys ever think
about dying?
-♪ Charles is the newest king ♪
♪ Coronation was boring ♪
♪ For a more exciting time,
throw yourself
down this big slide ♪
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-♪ UFOs from Mexico ♪
♪ Divorce for de Blasio ♪
♪ A congresswoman
made the news when she... ♪
-Got handsy at
a performance of "Beetlejuice."
-♪ So much stuff
while we were gone ♪
♪ Zuckerberg against Elon ♪
♪ Biden's dog bit everyone ♪
♪ And Colorado coach Deion ♪
♪ And girl-dinner phenomenon ♪
♪ And reborn Bed Bath & Beyond ♪
♪ And final tour for
Elton John ♪
♪ And Messi is Floridian ♪
♪ And bye-bye to "Succession" ♪
♪ And Seacrest hosts
"Wheel of Fortune" ♪
♪ And Coco won U.S. Open ♪
♪ And this show
is a brand-new one ♪
♪ I've missed you all,
and that's the truth ♪
♪ My great writers
and awesome crew ♪
♪ I couldn't do this
without you ♪
♪ Now give it up for The Roots ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]